All right. So, welcome to the basement.
Um, you know, it was interesting first
coming walking down here after it's so
big and beautiful up there and coming
down here. I'm like, am I going to go
into the right place? Um, but, uh, the
acoustics are better.
So, anyways, um, I'm going to talk a
little bit today about establishing AI
governance without stifling innovation.
Um, I'm going to have to kind of give a
little bit of a background about it
because I work for a company called
TripleF Enterprises, which most probably
like no one's ever heard of. And so I've
got to kind of explain what we do, which
kind of knocks software development,
right? Um, as well as, you know, kind of
our method kind of went through how we
originally met with the different
executive teams, met with outside
consultants and started to develop an AI
road map and then realizing we needed
governance and thought we were handling
it well and then kind of ran into some
issues where we're like, okay, this is
what we would have done differently. And
hopefully those lessons learned are
helpful for you guys. Um,
so a bit about FFF Enterprises. Uh,
we're basically like a baby McKessan.
We're a $5 billion like pharmaceutical
distribution company, but we also have
IoT mini fridge devices, kind of like a
Vegas mini fridge, but with drugs in
them atarmacies and hospitals. Um, we
have a couple different software
divisions. We actually have an online
pharmacy. We have nurses that go do um
like IV drugs and things like that, but
we like we focus on specialty drugs,
which is a whole area of pharmacy. So,
we don't compete that much directly with
uh you know the big three. Um but that
kind of giving you a background of kind
of our size and us not being software
forward, right? Because we were not
really tech forward. We're just
distributing things, taking orders by
fax and things like that back in the
day. But we're trying to really move to
have tech kind of really kind of help us
out in the future and where we want to
go.
>> Did you guys Is there a Hey guys in the
back? Is there a way to start the clock?
>> Oh, it just popped up. Perfect. Thank
you. No, it's going. It's going now.
Just want I just want to make sure I
don't talk too much, which I like to do.
So, all right. So, but now we're kind of
using tech advantage. myself. I started
very tech forward. You know, my first IT
job was helping people connect to dialup
and it just kind of cascaded from there.
Um where I was a network engineer,
network administrator, manage IT
departments, got into cyber security,
swung over to GRC for a while and then
but everything kind of really came back
except maybe not dialup but you know to
help me out as the CISO over here at F
Enterprises and and I've been there for
a little over 5 years. Um so our
original roadmap so we my my boss is the
CIO and he went out you know with
grabbed a consulting firm like let's AI
you know and he came in and worked with
these people they sat down with
different VPs and and different folks
not me
and they came up with like we have these
40 AI projects and we're going to and
PMO is like we'll release them in five
waves and we'll have everything this is
in 2025 we'll have everything done by
2027. seven. Um, so I mean we had use
cases across the board like within HR,
with our pharmacy distribution, within
our pharmacy itself where I can explain
one of them that's pretty cool later.
Um, but that's dealing with PHI, we had
sales, finance, so a lot of different
types of data and you know I was kind of
like you know I come and see the the
presentation you know at the end of the
from what the consultants did and I'm
like uh we got a problem guys like we we
haven't really thought this out.
So kind of first way I kind of started
doing this was like okay well let's
let's get like proposed kind of a tiered
governance platform right so we kind of
have the head of the governance
committee which is myself the CIO our
general counsel our chief compliance
officer and the and these are the kind
of like the top level you know we're out
there pushing down policies we're
talking about ethics we're we're really
trying to focus on regulatory um you
know obviously me on the security side
but we kind of wanted to shrink that
down a bit farther And so we created
kind of an AI center of excellence
there. And that's kind of more VPs and
director levels, some special managers.
Uh those are the guys in charge of data
science that are sitting on that board.
People inside of the infrastructure that
are building it. Um you know, we have HR
sitting there as well because they've
been really helpful for us on enablement
and training, right? Because not
everybody is excited about hearing about
AI is taking your jobs because that's
what it says everywhere, right? So
they're like, "No, it's not going to do
So we were like we're trying to like
show people on kind of ways that we kind
of do it around to like make them
excited about it. Um so HR has been very
helpful for that. Um and and they then
they were kind of working in in that
area on standardized practices, shared
services. Um you know working along with
me with controls but getting more and
more specific as we go down. And you
know in the future what we're hoping to
is kind of have a catalog of you know
different use cases that we kind of
shift between the departments and stuff
like that and kind of have an AI review
board like an agent checkout so to speak
right and so the smaller level area
where a manager might just be able to go
reach out to somebody on the cloud
center sorry the AI center of excellence
and just check out that use case and if
there's not a lot of stuff doing it
there. So if we think about it too,
another way to look at that is is kind
of on the the risk level, right? So
anything that's looking very risky like
if we're touching PHI if there's a lot
of PII it starts getting pushed up to
the higher committees um you know and
you know my security architect who's on
the center of excellence board should be
pushing things helping to push things to
me you know VP of pharmacy those who
work with PHI ethical stuff with with HR
all those kind of so the further the
risk the higher up it goes that's the
idea and so that's what we tried to
start putting together um because the
goal of AI governance to balance the
value and the risk.
Some of the other things we kind of
looked at there um is we saw those 40
use cases and we're like this is a lot
you know like and how do we even know is
what's going to be good what's going to
be you know really a use case where
we're going to find that value or are we
just wasting time and money and putting
ourselves at risk. But so we we we first
decided like well we need to create
intake forms you know include different
things to look at um you know expect we
wanted to make sure that people would
like have an idea what their process is
now what the metrics they wanted to be
in their future. We didn't kind of get
that far in depth the first time around.
We're just like oh we'll have some risk
assessments. You just tell us how we'll
kind of judge on how much technical work
it's going to be. Uh you know you tell
us what you're expecting.
Um you know and we also you know we we
provided training for folks you know
that we didn't realize how depth it
would have to go. Um you know we wanted
to have controls embedded controls and
system design. So access controls is one
thing that we want to make sure that the
agents or the people have like the right
amount of access and how we're going to
do that. We went with like how we're
going to monitor everything. Let's put
that together. Can we kind of see what's
going on? Um and then you know we wanted
to be able to eventually and this is
kind of you know we're running at the
same time we're still already moving
forward with a couple use cases and you
know we want we want to understand how
to audit them later and how to alert on
any issues that we're running into. Um
and so initially we're like what we need
to do is kind of focus on one control
plane you know of what we want to do you
know you know we didn't you know go
build an MCP server or anything but we
we have data bricks so they're like
we're going to funnel most everything we
can through data bricks right outside of
you know if people want to use you know
a chatbot we're going to put all that
side with co-pilot and Microsoft because
again $5 billion company we have the
money for fancy software and We're a
Microsoft shop. So kind of kind of
forced into that uh that there. So we
kind of set these things up thinking,
okay, this this should be enough, right?
This should really help us to go
forward. We we've thought about it, you
know, and you know, I've already held my
boss back for two months on this, you
know, cuz it was a initially our CEO is
like no AI. Uh let's not do that. And
then my boss finally convinced him and
then he was like, I want it now. And and
it was like it was the end of, you know,
like I said, it was 2025. I hadn't had
budget for it cuz I was told no. So, we
had to like pull in a little bit of
emergency budget and stuff like that,
but uh it's been a hurry up and go thing
ever since.
All right. So, you know, everything
obviously didn't have 100% success like
the little happy robot on the bottom of
that last picture. Um we really figured
out we needed to do a lot more. We had
created an AI usage policy that said,
"Hey, check with it before you use AI."
You know, that was that was what we put
out. That's compliance and legal put
that together. I'm like, "Seems good.
Seems legit." Uh, we needed something
way more specific, right? We needed to
be able to list specifically these are
approved tooling tools you could use.
These are specifically prohibited
technologies, but use cases as well. So
when people were like uh we have some
software that does work for medical
trials for instance you know like that's
very very touchy. So it's like that's
prohibited. So someone has to make a
really good reason and come around
through with us and yes we're going to
be doing something there but you know
that has to be brought through through
the governance committee but the the
general policy is like please don't do
that. you know, we want we want to make
sure the policy had shows that everyone
who's using it is required to go through
AI awareness training and they got to
sign off. We took that our normal
acceptable use policy, you know, where
it's like, hey, you know, we're going to
be watching you. Don't do bad things on
the internet. Don't post on social media
and got really a little bit more
in-depth with things you can do with AI.
Um, and if you want examples, I can
share some of those later um outside of
this. Um but I think that was something
that really helped. Um we also uh to
help adoption we started getting people
like in you know we had a co-pilot
adoption thing so we're doing that and
so people be like these are the use
cases I'm using but having people within
departments kind of really championing
it. Um I was glad to see it work because
I have been trying very hard to always
get a security champion in each
department or a risk management champion
in each department. Um AI seemed to be a
little bit better. they seem to enjoy
that. So,
you know, some of the other pieces on
there as well was where does it require
human oversight? Again, speaking of the
medical trial piece, uh, one of our use
cases that we're currently using, one of
the first use cases we deployed was
medical pre-authorization.
So, we do a lot of work with immune
drugs and what happens is some of our
patients, well, they just automatically
get denied because it's expensive.
That's really kind of what the
healthcare companies do. So, we created
an agent go through and pull all they'd
read the letters on why they're denied.
They'd pull all the proper
documentation, wrap it up in a pretty
bow, and then a doctor would review it
and approve that or not. Um, that's the
$250,000 use case. Uh, my b my boss is
like, "Yeah, we're saving $250,000 a
year on this thing. It's pretty cool."
Um, and and it's really great to help
people out. Um, so we that was like,
"This requires human oversight." Uh
we've also understood in another use
case because I think use cases are kind
of exciting so should probably bring
them up right. Um another use case we're
using is using multiple agents and this
is for a distribution company for you
know overages, shortages, damages and
shipping goods. So people can log a
complaint on our e our SAP e-commerce
site which then throws a notice over to
Salesforce. the saleserson knows what's
going on and then that reach you know
and then we re this is all being
orchestrated within different agents
within data bricks which reaches out to
SAP pulls ship date all this other
information pulls all these documents
together you know passes it to this
orchestrator agent that builds
everything around it and then hands this
long document including you know any
images that the customer might upload um
and and eventually we have video like
over you know where people are packing
So, I mean, we have like, you know,
$13,000 vials of drugs that go out
sometimes. So, we got to make sure
people don't, you know, harm them, you
know, make sure put it in. Um, but then
it pieces all that together for someone
to review and get back with the customer
and it saves a lot of time. So, you
know, where do you put the human review
in the loop? We're still very much on
the risk adverse side. So, we're kind of
leaning that direction. The more we can
do, the better.
Um in yeah I'd mentioned the sign off
definitely unacceptable use policy the
training more and more sign off our my
legal team is very signature happy I
don't know you know we're in the state
of California I'm not sure how much it's
going to protect you uh but you know
they're happy that people do sign off um
stricter AI intake I mentioned earlier
kind of having you know what's the
benefit of this so why should we do it
and now we're kind of really what is
your process currently like does it take
you how long this process take? How much
do you think this will make it
improvement? And if you want to work
with our data team or whomever to talk
through how is this going to actually do
you think it's going to work better?
Let's do that. And so we have an intake
form, you know, and then as we're
evaluating use cases, we have a risk
form and they fill out does this touch
PHI? How's this, you know, like does
this affect a critical process? And we
go through quite a few different areas
there so that we can really start
looking at prioritizing use cases. And
uh turns out a lot of those 40 initial
use cases. Some of them are just they
just want they just want a nice report
pulled from two different things. It's
nothing this is something they can do
like it's a small task. You know it's
not what they it's not building this
magic AI thing. It's really just okay
I'm taking some numbers from Salesforce
and SAP and put them together. So we're
you know we're we're working through
that still as we go forward. Um but you
know creating those scorecards for use
cases so you understand the
prioritization has really helped us kind
of try to streamline this and understand
kind of where we're going forward
because otherwise every business
division wants it at the same time. Um
usually governance committee will be
able to kind of make that call but um I
do not sit on the executive team
formally but everyone else on the
governance committee does. So sometimes
it gets bumped up, you know, to my CEO
and others and the CFO that might, you
know, pull the strings, but usually we
we get to make the decisions, which is
nice. Um, but having those success
measures and benchmarking ahead of time
based on all this stuff is is really
helpful cuz, you know, in the end we do
want to show that it is saving us
$250,000 or this is how much time it
saved. I think it's really important
that you know people be able to do that
and maybe you know with some better
control planning on access controls. We
have kind of a I like to call it
security ouus spaghetti and sometimes
it's hard to figure out who's got
control where and kind of cleaning some
of that that up and you know right now
while we're focusing heavy on co-pilot
and data bricks it's a little easier but
as we expand we know we want to have
different divisions to be able to build
their own agents whether it's through AI
we have one division right now that's on
the software side of thing that that is
building their own AI stuff but that's
kind of in demo mode. We're kind of
testing with them, getting all the best
practices before we launch it out for
everybody else. Um, but that's kind of
what we need to do. And then obviously
shadow AI. Um, that's that's a
definitely going to be a big one for me
uh chasing down later this year. Um,
is ridiculous as it sounds. You know,
I'm you know, my procurement team is
like my best friend there because then,
you know, I'm working with legal and
procurement on getting everything into
contract so we know if there's AI on
use. if we know if there's private you
know if there's nothing in PII but you
know do they have AI too like where are
the data being kept what models are they
using um so we're starting to kind of
work that in with the procurement for
third party risk so we're slowly getting
there um this was a I asked uh you know
I asked co-pilot I was like hey what
what's something like you know we're
we're designing this thing but it grew
legs and I was like but make it sound
kind of nerdy and they were like you
know we were aiming for controlled
execution but it spawned child processes
But, uh, that's me and that's kind of I
hope that was kind of helpful and, uh, I
just wanted to kind of throw out a
couple of use cases, but if you have
questions, go right ahead.
>> Hey, hello again.
>> Okay.
>> No,
>> what are you what are you doing about
prompt injection?
We're so most things right now on for
end users uh we're going secure browsers
for the method of kind of blocking as
much as we can there. If they even if
they try to go to chat GBT, it just
forces them over to our our instance of
C-pilot. Um and if people start, you
know, if you're cutting and pasting
within, you know,
like code to have something that will
review your code, it'll rip out keys and
stuff like that. So secure browsers have
been good for us um in that area. On the
other side, we're hoping the controls
within data bricks are solving for for
our agents there. I mean, I'm not, you
know, selling data bricks, but there's
some cool stuff they can do in the
monitoring for like hallucinations and
things like that where we can set
baselines. This is what we're expected.
If it's out of there, it alerts us. Um,
but I still think we need to go through
and build a better audit program to come
back to see if there's been like a slow
movement in out of where we need the
norm that we want to go. And if somebody
just signs up with their credit card
for, you know, pro version of some new
platform that's shadow AI, how do you
detect that?
>> We're we've we've, you know, I know you
guys released some stuff uh that we tie
back into CrowdStrike when Open Claw
came out, that whole stuff. So, we
actually worked off that when after the
cloud security alliance kind of posted
that. Um, and so that was kind of
helpful. We're again, you know, I can
kind of see where people are going some
with secure browser, but I don't think
we're going to catch all of it. You
know, especially when it's like, okay,
well, I can say claude, but how does it
detect if it's an AI piece? There's
still improvements we need to do.
>> I'm not sure who was next. I'll go here.
>> Hi. Uh, the stricter AI intake, what
phase is that happening at? Because we
have people delivering code so fast,
right? Like we don't have a tiered
blueprint. I have two follow-up
questions which is I love the scorecard
idea. How are you dimensioning risk?
Like risk is could be risk of them
training on my data. It could be like
almost anything. So if you could talk
about the risk dimensions that'd be
awesome.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So um on the coding software
side that's definitely harder slow down
when it's the business coming to us and
ask us to build something for them.
That's kind of where we're doing that
that better job of it. Um we the risk
intake form has been been modified
like I don't know almost every new use
case because something comes up. Um
which means you know of course you know
the vision of the governance board only
coming in when there's high risk. No.
No. That means I'm hands-on on a lot of
stuff initially. Um but I mean we've
we've kind of covered a lot of stuff
with usage of data. Um patient data
makes it easy. I mean we're a businessto
business pharmaceutical distribution
company. So like most of the stuff we're
doing is not secret not we're not
worried about that data. There's no
there's not much IP there but you know
and then patient data obviously. So for
us like a lot of times it is very black
and white you know if we need more um
but some of the use cases
usually when more access is needed than
should be for certain people like this
well you know you're kind of combining
this process that has a lot of you know
financial data that shouldn't be exposed
to everybody and that's where we're
seeing some of the stuff where kind of
re have to ask those risk questions.
I had a quick question on um the saying
the intake form.
Can you share any successes on making
that friction-free and the path of least
resistance being the safest path versus
them circumventing it because it's
overhead and they just want to go? Any
wins there you can share?
>> Is to insert friction?
>> Yeah, I I mean and and I think a lot of
it is because
we're controlling the keys and forcing
everybody through data bricks again. we
only know what we're we're trying to do,
right? And so they can't get too far of
anywhere without our help currently. Um,
but no, I I think it's been it's been
tough for people. We've we have a pretty
strong like project intake PMO process,
so people are kind of used to that. Um,
you know, when you're getting your
funding, you're assigning the resources.
I mean, it's $5 million, so we're kind
of a little slower there. So, I think
that helps. It wasn't like out of the
blue we needed that. But
>> thank you. We still catch things during
the change management phases that I
wasn't told about.
>> Okay. We're just um I think we have one
more question while we still get AB up.
So you had a question.
>> So you're using uh data bricks as your
authorization platform. Everything's
going through that particular service.
It's not integrating anywhere else.
>> Correct. So that's that's I mean it's
talking but you know a data bricks
Salesforce AI agent is talking to the
Salesforce AI agent within Salesforce.
Um and same thing with Juul with an
>> so you've got great authorization on all
of that.
>> Well as much as we can doing and I'm
still learning more about labeling
within data bricks to you know make sure
and shrink the controls back to
especially when it comes to users and
active directory groups. Like I said the
spaghetti groups have too much security.
So,
>> so you're thinking about integrating it
somewhere else within those maybe active
directory owned maybe Microsoft product
sets
>> and I know it's not going to stay in
there. So, we're we were trying to keep
going on but I I told my boss let's
start here. You didn't give me budget to
buy you know AI specific security tool
set but we'd love to look.
>> Thank you.
>> Okay. How are we doing on AV?
>> Okay. Well, I have a question for you.
you mentioned um so there's this whole
notion of SAS being disrupted and uh
this notion of being a system of context
rather than a system of record.
>> Uh do do you understand what that
concept means or how have you embraced
that sort of concept within uh FFF?
>> If you can explain a little bit more
what you mean by system concepts.
>> Well, so you were talking about some of
the services that you're using like
Service Now, Salesforce, whatever. And
each company is trying to be what they
call the system of context. Not system
of record but system of context which is
to be the centerpoint for
>> everything.
>> Everything right so now you have but you
have two products who are buying to be a
system of context.
>> So how are you uh trying to reconcile
that? We're and I think that's where
we're kind of leaving things within data
bricks because it's because we have our
two main systems of context really are
Salesforce and SAP but we're shoving it
all into data bricks and making that our
main system.
>> So you're creating your own system of
context effectively. Okay.
>> Right. And and you know just being able
to like you know bronze, silver, gold
data standards within it has been
helpful.
>> Okay. Very good.